Guten Tag.
Ich bin heute ständig für Sie und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ich heiße Aisha Chenig.
Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Andrea Krab.
Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname langsam bürsten?
Ja.
Krab schreibt sich K, R, A, P, P.
Okay, Frau Krab.
Andrea Krab, Frau Krab, ja.
Wie heißen Sie Frau Krab?
Ich bin 56 Jahre.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 26. März, 166.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
70 kg.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Krab, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe so seit ungefähr 6 Stunden so heftige Brustschmerzen.
So links, linke Brustseite.
Linke Brustseite, okay.
Haben Sie enge Gefühle im Brustkorb?
Wenn ich atmen will, dann wird das schlimmer.
Aber enge Gefühle, ich trau mich nicht zu atmen.
Das tut so weh, das schmerzt.
Ja, beim Atmen.
Das tut so weh.
Das tut so weh, das schmerzt.
Ja, beim Einatmen haben Sie schlechtes Schmerzen.
Ja.
Haben Sie Husten auch?
Nein.
Und Ihre Beschwerden sind vor 6 Stunden angefangen?
Ja, ziemlich plötzlich, ja.
Beim Tennis spielen.
Beim Tennis spielen, okay.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall bekommen?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Frau Krabb, hatten Sie diese Beschwerden schon noch einmal in der Vergangenheit?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Das ist das erste Mal.
Zum ersten Mal.
Okay, haben Sie jetzt Luftnot?
Ich trau mich nicht richtig einzuatmen, weil es dann so weh tut.
Ja, ja.
Ich hole immer nur etwas Luft.
Frau Krabb, zuerst möchte ich Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Zum Beispiel Ihre Blut-Sauerstoff-Sättigung und Ihre Bluthochblutdruck und Ihre Puls.
Dann können wir weitermachen.
Okay.
Ja, wir haben alles überprüft.
Und Sie sind sehr stabil zurzeit.
Wir können weitermachen.
Ja.
Frau Krabb, wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen einstufen, von 1 bis 10 auf einer Stikale?
1 bedeutet sehr leicht, 10 bedeutet sehr stark Schmerzen.
Ah, zwischen 6 und 7.
6 und 7.
Okay. Hatten Sie Fieber?
Nein, kein Fieber.
Hatten Sie andere Begleitsymptome, oder Luftnot, oder eine Weimeinatmische Schmerzen?
Ja, beim Einatmen, da verstärkt sich der Schmerz.
Wenn ich tief einatmen würde, dann zieht das so richtig von hinten nach vorne.
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht gut gehört. Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Wenn ich tief einatme, dann verstärkt sich der Schmerz.
Dann geht er von hinten bis nach vorne in die Brust.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Fühlen Sie Ihr Herz schneller?
Nein.
Okay, ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, ist mir nicht übel.
Haben Sie Vorerkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Was verstehen Sie unter Vorerkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel, Zuckerkrankheit, Bruthochdruck oder Brutfettwerte?
Ja, ich habe etwas hohen Blutdruck.
Seit 5 Jahren nehme ich auch ein Medikament ein.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Das heißt, Kandisatan, nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends eine halbe Tablette.
Entschuldigung, ich habe wieder nicht gut gehört.
Kandisatan?
Und wie viel Milligramm?
4 Milligramm.
Einmal am Tag?
Einem Tablett morgens und eine halbe Tablette abends.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Vorerkrankungen, Zuckerkrankheit, Bruthochdruck oder Brutdruck?
Nein, Zuckerkrankheit nicht.
Ich bin operiert worden.
Ja, wann?
Vor 4 Jahren.
Die Schilddrüse zu groß.
Die Schilddrüse ist operiert, verkleinert worden.
Seitdem muss ich auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Was ist das Medikament, nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme Ältiroxin 75.
Eine Tablette morgens.
Okay, verstehe.
Ältiroxin, nehmen Sie etwas anderes ein?
Nein, nichts.
Und Sie wurden nur einmal operiert?
Als Kind.
Als Kind wurde ich auch schon mal operiert an den Mandeln.
Da war ich, glaube ich, 8 Jahre alt.
Und dann wurde ich noch operiert mit 11 Jahren am Blindern.
Okay.
Sind diese Operationen Komplikationen aus Verfahren?
Da war alles in Ordnung. Es ist alles gut verlaufen.
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch oder haben Sie etwas Unverträglichkeiten gegen Lebensmitteln?
Also ich vertrage nicht gut Erdbeeren und Kiwi.
Was ist mit Ihnen passiert, wenn Sie diese Obst essen?
Ich habe etwas Brennen im Mund und etwas Bläschen im Mund.
Nur im Mund?
Ja.
Okay, natürlich. Essen Sie nichts.
Okay.
Frau Krab, gibt es irgendwelche wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie
oder vererbete Erkrankungen?
Der Vater ist mit 80 Jahren verstorben, er hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Es tut mir leid. Und Ihre Mutter?
Die Mutter ist 86 Jahre jetzt alt und sie lebt und hat auch hohen Blutdruck,
Atrose in der Hüfte und im Knie.
Beide. Beide Hüfte, beide Knie?
Ja, ziemlich. Aber sie ist nicht bisher operiert worden.
Sie ist nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstalt, Frau Krab?
Ich bin verheiratet, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Ich habe nicht gehört. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich habe verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder.
Okay, sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, die sind gesund.
Dabei gibt es nichts Besonderes.
Sind Sie Rentnerin, Frau Krab?
Nein, ich arbeite noch als Lehrerin.
Sehr schön. Und bekommen Sie Ihre Periode noch?
Nein.
Okay, Frau Krab, brauchen Sie?
Nein, habe noch nie geraucht.
Sehr schön. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber nur ganz selten. Vielleicht einmal in der Woche,
ein Glas Wein.
Sehr, sehr schön.
Und mit Drogen haben Sie nichts zu tun, nehme ich mal an?
Nein.
Okay, gut.
Okay, Frau Krab, haben wir alles gespürt? Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was glauben Sie, was dieser Schmerz, wo der herkommt?
Was das sein kann?
Ja, ich möchte so erst eine Zusammenfassung machen.
Und vielleicht können Sie etwas noch hinzufügen.
Seit sechs Stunden haben Sie linke Brustschmerzen.
Und dass diese Schmerzen schüttert in den Rücken aus.
Sie fangen Sie im Rücken an?
Ja, kommt vorne.
Im Rücken und geht da nach vorne.
Okay, verstehe.
Diese Schmerzen sind beim Tennisspielen aufgetreten, plötzlich.
Und das ist sehr stark auf einer Skala.
Einstufen Sie 6 oder 7 ein.
Und Sie haben beim Einatmen schwere Schmerzen.
Beim Tiefatmen ist es so schwer für Ihnen.
Sie haben keine Husten, keine Auswürfe und kein Fieber, kein Öbelkeit.
Genau.
Ja.
Okay.
Was will ich noch fragen?
Welche Hand benutzen Sie?
Ich habe Ihre Hand krippelt, Taubhausgefühl bemerkt.
Welche Hand ich benutze beim Tennisspielen?
Ja.
Links?
Links.
Linksenderin?
Ja, Ihre Links hat irgendwelche Taubhausgefühle, Kraft,
Bossigkeit, Schwere oder Bewegung abhängig schmeißen.
Nicht so richtig.
Vielleicht etwas weniger Kraft, aber nicht so richtig.
Kein Taubhausgefühl, kein Kribbeln.
Aber es begann beim Tennisspielen, plötzlich war der Schmerz da.
Wie schnell sind die Schmerzen?
Genau, wir schreiben, sind sie ja dumpf stechen, bläden und...
Ja, es war schon mehr so stechend.
Das war wie so ein kleiner Messer.
Ein kleiner Messerstich.
Im Laufe derzeit zerstört, oder?
Es ist ziemlich gleich geblieben, aber ich habe auch Schmerzen,
wenn ich mich so anlehne, am Rücken und nach hinten lehne,
tut das auch weh.
Das ist vielleicht schlimmer und stärker.
Ja, aber ich habe das nie gehabt so.
Haben Sie Ihre Haut bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut geschwollt und gerötet
oder warm sind?
Nein, habe ich noch nicht bemerkt.
Nein?
Okay.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Haben Sie im Status gefragt?
Ich habe das nicht ganz genau gehört.
Im Status? Nein, habe ich nicht gefragt.
Was möchten Sie wissen beim Impfstatus?
Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 völlig geimpft?
Ich bin dreimal geimpft und einmal genesen.
Gut.
Wenn Sie Schmerzen haben, ist die Geschichte etwas selben.
Zum Beispiel Schmerzen und Schwindelig.
Ich traue mich nur nicht, tief zu atmen.
Ich kann tief Luft holen.
Ich atme nur ganz wenig, ganz oberflächlich.
Haben Sie Schmerzen nur beim Belastung oder in Ruhe?
Ich habe mich zu Hause etwas hinzulegen, auf die Seite zu drehen.
Am besten ist es noch, wenn ich sitze.
Wollen wir erst als Geschichte anfangen?
Ja.
Gut.
Ich bin bereit.
Ja, ich bin verfestigt.
Guten Tag Herr Oberlach.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten bekommen.
Ich würde gerne Sie bei Ihnen vorstellen.
Frau Kraft ist eine 56-jährige Patientin.
Sie hat sich bei uns seit 6 Stunden bestehender,
für das sich angefangen hat, linke Brustschmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen haben sich vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen haben sich plötzlich angefangen.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 und 7.
Die Patientin hat Schwierigkeiten beim tiefen Atmen.
Das tut sehr weh.
Sie hat seit keinem Wisspne,
aber sie vermeidet tief zu atmen.
Tiefe Inspiration.
Diese Schmerzen haben beim Tennisspiel angefangen.
Die Patientin erliegt diese Symptome zum ersten Mal.
Sie hat stehender, wie ein Messerstich beschrieben.
Sie hat keine andere begleichtes Symptoma, kein Fibre, kein Übelkeit.
Es gibt keine besondere begleichtes Symptoma.
Sie hat ein weiterer Hyperton,
seit 5 Jahren, dagegen nicht die Kandazarten ein.
2 Mal am Tag, morgens 5 mg, abends 2 und 5 mg.
Außerdem hat die Patientin seit 5 Jahren Hypatroide,
vor 4 Jahren bei der Patientin eine Troidektomie durchgeführt.
Sie nimmt dagegen Altroxin, 75 mg, einmal pro Tag.
Sie wurde 2 Mal operiert.
Als Kind hat sie Tonselektomie und Appendektomie gehabt.
Sie ist gegen Erdbeeren und Kiwi allergisch.
Diese allergische Äußerung bricht sich in den Mund.
Sie hat keine systemische Symptome.
In der Familiengeschichte gibt es bei der Vater einen Schlaganfall.
Er ist mit diesem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Die Mutter der Patientin leidet eine arterielle Hypertonie
und Kokosartros und Gonartros.
Die Patientin ist verheiratet und hat 2 Kinder.
Sie ist Lehrerin vom Beruf.
Sie ist in Wechseljahre.
Die Patientin braucht nichts und nimmt keine Drogen.
Sie trinkt selten Alkohol.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Pneumotorax.
Was kommt differentialdiagnostisch in Betracht?
Akut Coronarsandrum kann sein.
Was kommt das letzte?
Coronarsandrum.
Und wungenem Body kommt auch in Betracht.
Was kann man sagen?
Es gibt noch einen Vorschlag der Differenzialdiagnostik.
Als Diagnostische-Massnahme.
Nein, Differenzialdiagnostische.
Was ist der Differenzialdiagnose?
Eventuell in Betracht.
Wie bei solchen Fragen?
Es gibt viele Verletzungen.
Es waren mehr die internistischen Diagnosen.
Ich komme gleich noch mal drauf.
Sie haben die Anamnese-Behebung systematisch gemacht.
Sehr strukturiert.
Sie haben auch Möglichkeiten gegeben, zurückzufragen.
In der Sprache der Patientin.
Sie haben das dann auch gut übersetzt.
Bei der Vorstellung beim Proberarzt.
Ich habe gesagt, der Schmerz begann hinten.
Da habe ich vielleicht der Wirbelsäule.
Ich habe dann nach vorne gezogen beim Atmen.
Ich würde lieber sagen, die Patientin stellt sich vor,
mit links Turakalen beschwerten.
Sie haben nur das mit links Turakalen beschwerten.
Das ist gleich so.
Was ich für eine Diagnose stellen wollte,
ist, bei der Dynamik beim Tennis spielen,
hat sie eine akute Blockierung der Brustwirbelsäule bekommen.
Das ist der sogenannten Rippengelenkes.
Ostotransversalgelenk.
Das geht ganz schnell so eine Blockierung.
Meist aus einer Bewegung heraus, nicht aus der Ruhe.
Der Pneumotorax,
ob der so einen akuten Schmerz sofort macht,
weiß ich nicht so genau.
Muss man daran denken, ganz klar.
Das ist eine akute BWS-Symptomalik.
Mit einer Blockierung, sagen wir jetzt mal, der 5.6. Rippe.
Das ist typischer Schmerz,
dass die Leute beim Einatmen nicht richtig
auf die Hand halten können,
weil der Turak sich hebt und dann die Nervenwurzel irritiert.
Das kann aber imitieren.
Ein Herzbedingten-Schmerz,
Coronasyndrom, es kann eine eventuelle Pluritis imitieren.
Einatmen tut weh.
Die Richtung mit Pneumotorax ist schon richtig.
Wichtig ist sicherlich,
dass sie so etwas wie ein Coronasyndrom, Pneumotorax,
auf alle Fälle direkt versuchen auszuschließen.
Eine Brustwirbelsäule Blockierung ist nicht lebensbedrohlich.
Es ist keine vitale Bedrohung.
Deswegen hätte das etwas Zeit.
Aber wichtig ist EKG-Schreiben, Troponintest.
Sie haben die Vitalwerte schon kontrolliert zu Anfang.
Das war sehr gut.
Meine Arbeitsdiagnose war beim Tennisspielen,
als Linkshänderin durch einen Aufschlag oder Schlag da,
hat es blockiert.
Ich habe das selbst schon mal gehabt.
Das ist ein ganz wirklich dummer Schmerz
und habe das in der Praxis sehr oft erlebt bei Patienten.
Natürlich muss man eine kardiale
oder pulmonale Ursache ausschließen.
Deshalb gehört bei solchen Patienten immer ein EKG-Schreiben,
ein Troponintest gemacht,
vielleicht noch eine Lungenfunktion,
das auch immer.
Man muss es zumindest im Kopf behalten,
dass so etwas differenzial diagnostisch da ist.
Man kann das relativ gut, wenn man sich sicher ist,
in der Praxis schon beheben.
Dann gehen die Patienten meist beschwerdefrei wieder raus.
Es war jetzt ja kein Fachgespräch über bestimmte Erkrankungen.
Nur daran denken noch mal auch,
es kann eben auch etwas Panales sein.
Ihnen war ja schon Richtung Zoster.
Herr bis Zoster mit den Bläschen oder der Hautveränderung,
macht in der Regel aber nicht so ein ganz besonderes
und plötzlich eintretendes Schmerz.
Das baut sich ja oft ein bisschen auf,
dass erst gar keine Effluorizenzen da sind.
Erst ist dieser Brennenschmerz auf der Haut
und ein paar Tage später kommen die Bläschen,
die Effluorizenzen.
Aber so sollten Sie sich mal zur Prüfung anmelden.
Hoffentlich.
Wenn ich einen Zern empfinde.
Ja, dann.
Aber in dieser Krankheit habe ich zum ersten Mal gehört.
Schauen Sie unter akutes BWS-Syndrom,
also eine orthopädische Fragestellung,
oder auch Rippenblockierung.
Rippenblockierung, also Kostotransfersalblockierung.
Das kann sehr unangenehm und sehr schmerzhaft sein.
Gerade das Liegen oder das Umdrehen im Bett tut dann sehr weh.
Das ist in der Regel, wenn ich mich im Bett umdrehe und es schmerzt,
ist es in der Regel nicht vom Herzen kommend
oder nicht unbedingt internistisches Meer,
sondern das ist dann oft etwas orthopädisches.
Ja, klar.
Natürlich.
Kann es ein akutes Ereignis schon sein im Bereich der Pleuror,
oder der Lume?
Ganz klar.
Da gebe ich Ihnen recht.
Aber gut, einfach ein bisschen noch schauen.
Manchmal ist es auch etwas Einfacheres in der Diagnose.
Oder Banales, sagen wir mal so.
Aber wichtig ist zuerst immer,
die potenzielle lebensbedrohlichen Erkrankungen auszuschließen
und dann vielleicht zu den anderen Dingen zu gehen.
Aber das ist ja auch ein sehr wichtiges Problem.
Aber das haben Sie ja schon durch Überprüfung,
Vitalparameter und so weiter schon gut gemacht.
Aus meiner Sicht.